you think that's important for an
independent artist to stay
very consistent in running up the
catalog even though because i think
sometimes we like artists overthink
putting [ __ ] out sometimes i'm sure
you've you've crossed that bridge as an
artist where you're like you're sitting
on something
it might have been fire but nine months
later you're like i'm over this [ __ ] and
it never comes out i never felt i never
had that i never had to happen you're a
[ __ ] alien then no it's not because i
think i think independent artists do
work different in that in that way
whereas like um when you're independent
artists getting some success
like you're always dropping you know
what i mean like yeah you're always
dropping because you got to stay
relevant and i feel like as an indie
you don't the only way you stay relevant
is either like you keep dropping records
or you're doing something else that's
keeping you relevant in the music space
non-stop yeah but you have to you have
to stay in front of people you got to
keep putting shots up right right yeah
and if the shots don't make it it's not
as big of a deal as if you're on a major
right because if you drop an album and
it flops on a major who gives a [ __ ] or
no there is a big there's a lot of money
behind it but if you're independent you
just move on and put something else out
exactly you don't have to you there's no
embarrassment you know there's no like
oh this didn't work out for me it's like
not just do that [ __ ] again you know
there's nobody saying like there's less
pressure because if you put out a record
that doesn't do so well
only you're the only one that's going to
be disappointed you don't have label
people that are like damn like maybe
he's not selling like he used to or
maybe everybody's doubting you now when
now the pressure is on you to be like
damn like and and maybe i got to put up
make music like this so maybe i got to
change my style and then you start
questioning yourself so like being indie
is just like bro i dropped this record
it didn't do that well then get on new
music friday whatever
i'ma drop another one and maybe this one
will and that really was how my career
went it's just like yo with every week
every other week you know so um how do
you want to be remembered when it's all
said and done man like what do you want
your legacy to be
um
i just want to be remembered
as somebody some dude that says some
real [ __ ] on the record you know it's
like
um i gotta i i got on
into this music [ __ ] and i said what was
on my mind
and i helped people
navigate life and
like
that's it and i was you know i was a
part of that journey and a part of it
like personal growth and emotional
growth that's it